dans
[Musique]
ses caisses joie je suis à la fois une
fable racisées que et suisse et j'ai un
parcours plutôt atypique
je suis né dans une petite maison de la
ville de ses manies au kurdistan du sud
au nord de l'irak
et comme je suis né pile au moment du
lever du soleil ma mère a décidé de
m'appeler casio a parce que quasi mois
aux kurdes ça désigne le premiers rayons
du soleil le matin et c'était pour elle
une manière de donner du sens à une
naissance qui arrivait durant l'une des
périodes les plus sanglants du peuple qu
il faut savoir que mes parents étaient
tous les deux deux activistes engagés
pour l'indépendance du kurdistan et à ce
titre
tous les jours on risquer notre peau
alors très tôt dans mon parcours j'ai dû
quitter ma terre natale pour m'accrocher
à la vie et c'est comme ça qu'on a
débarqué en suisse en tant que réfugiés
politiques et qu'on a intégré le système
d'asile avec toutes les violences
systémique que ça représente moi j'ai
grandi dans le quartier du schoenberg ce
genre de quartier ou avoir pour nom de
famille damas a rien de surprenant ce
genre de quartier où tu trouves toujours
un copain ou une copine avec lequel
jouer quel que soit leur ce genre de
quartier où tous pas rentrer à la maison
pour faire pipi est-ce que tu as peur
que ta maman te demande de rester à la
maison tu vois le genre de quartier ça
pour vous dire que moi j'ai grandi ici
j'ai fait toutes mes études et j'ai même
obtenu ma naturalisation
et malgré ça évidemment que en
grandissant en suisse moi je me suis
intégré à la culture de mille et une
manières sans pour autant en oublier mes
origines ni mes racines mais quand même
au point où aujourd'hui
je fais la gueule devant un fromage
quand il put pas
évidemment que outre le fromage et le
chocolat moi j'ai remarqué que ans ici
comme ailleurs d'ailleurs il existe de
nombreuses injustices notamment dans la
manière dont sont traités les femmes
entre les féminicides la charge mentale
le harcèlement sexuel vous imaginez bien
que j'ai rapidement rejoint le rang des
féministes pour lutter activement contre
le sexisme je me suis passionné pour ces
questions là j'avais l'impression
d'avoir enfin trouvé ma place
et j'ai crié mais comme j'ai jamais
crier dans ma vie durant la grève du 14
juin
et malgré ça
malgré tout l'amour que je porte à mes
soeurs féministe j'ai réalisé que le
féminisme qu'elle défende est passé à
côté de quelque chose de fondamental
quand on partageait notre vécu des
discriminations
j'ai remarqué que c'était très différent
se faire bousculer dans la rue par un
mec qui vous crie d'or les étrangers bah
c'était du jamais vu pour elles elles
m'ont dit qu'elle se faisait jamais
fouillé à la douane par la frontière
qu'on les avait jamais traité de
terroriste et qu'on n'avait jamais au
grand jamais remis en question leur
légitimité d'exister sur le territoire
helvétique
alors forcément moi il finit par
comprendre que ce que je vivais c'était
ce qu'on appelle les discriminations
intersectionnelle parce qu'en plus du
sexisme que je vivais je vis aussi du
racisme
et ce à la discrimination
intersectionnelle c'est un principe qui
a été conceptualisée par la professeure
afro-américaine qui meurt et crenshaw en
fait quand tu te trouve à la croisée de
plusieurs identités qui sont
historiquement opprimés comme les femmes
et les personnes assises et tu seras
susceptibles de vivre d oppression en
simultané comme le sexisme et le racisme
en est le coup de génie de l'outil
intersectionnelle c'est que ça permet de
mettre le lien entre les identités
et les rapports de pouvoir
ce qui permet justement de se rendre
compte que dans notre société certaines
identités sont
systématiquement exclus des espaces de
pouvoir à la faveur de certaines autres
identités comme le fait d'être un homme
le fait d'être blanc le fallait être
hétéro qui vont justement monopolisé ces
espaces décisionnel politique
professionnelle et privée
et loti intersectionnelle ça permet en
fait de décloisonner ses frontières
rigide qu'on s'est inventé entre les
différentes formes d'oppression et le
but c'est de mieux nous adapter à la
réalité du vécu des personnes qui vivent
ces oppressions intersectionnelle ça ça
permet de nous éviter de se retrouver
dans des situations complètement
absurdes comme celles de la sphère des
gran fait ride qui s'est passé dans les
années 70 aux etats unis cinq femmes
noires ont porté plainte contre une
entreprise parce que celle ci refusait
systématiquement d'embaucher des femmes
noires
et malheureusement elles ont perdu leur
procès parce que légalement on pouvait
pas punir l'entreprise pour du sexisme
parce qu'ils ont gâché déjà des femmes
blanches ni pour du racisme parce qu'ils
engageaient déjà des hommes noirs
et qu'est-ce que ça démontre sa montre
que les lois antidiscriminatoires ne
protège les femmes racisées que dans la
mesure où leur expérience du sexies
coïncide avec celle des femmes blanches
et leur expérience du racisme avec celle
des personnes des hommes racisées autant
dire que l on aucune chance d'être
représentés
évidemment on entend dans toutes ces
histoires moi j'ai fini par réaliser que
en fait moi aussi je vivais des
discriminations intersectionnelle et ça
ça a permis de donner du sens à mes
expériences comme la fois où un type m'a
dit vous les femmes orientales moi ça me
fait rêver avec vos formes et votre
caractère bien trempé on s'ennuie jamais
quoi et moi je vous un vrai que sur le
moment j'ai juste pas compris j'ai pas
compris comment un type pouvait
s'imaginer que toute une population
avait la même morphologie et la même
personnalité
mais aujourd'hui je comprends
je comprends que c'est un phénomène qui
s'appelle la fétichisation raciale en
fait on va t exotisme sur la base ton
genre de ton origine et d'un certain
nombre de caractéristiques phénotypiques
comme la couleur de ta peau la texture
de ton cheveux la forme de tes yeux et
on va coller tout un imaginaire colonial
qui va te réduire à un objet de désir
exotiques
autrement dit
la personne ne va pas te désire et
romantiquement ou sexuellement pour qui
tu es
mais pour qu'elle figure caricaturale
d'un imaginaire à 6tu représente
évidemment
beaucoup de gens peuvent se dire
maintenant ça juste d'une question de
goûts et de couleurs ça va pas aussi
loin mais en réalité la fétichisation
raciale elle découle directement de la
colonisation qui je le rappelle c'est
accompagné de nombreux viols de femmes
racisées qui étaient perçus comme des
territoires à conquérir
et d'ailleurs ça explique pourquoi les
femmes arabes noirs latinos asiatiques
ne seront pas fétichisé tout à fait de
la même manière parce que les fantasmes
qu'on va coller sur ses diverses
catégories sont différents
les femmes noires sont souvent comparés
à des féroces l'yonne et les femmes
asiatiques à des geishas soumises
pas tout ça pour dire que en fait encore
aujourd'hui les femmes racisées continue
d'être fétichisé par des personnes qui
perpétue une logique coloniale souvent
sans même s'en rendre compte
et moi quand j'ai compris tout ça j'ai
eu envie de faire quelque chose alors
j'ai décidé avec ma meilleure amie faiza
si c'est de créer un podcast qui
s'appelle l'inconfortable et qui a pour
but de visible lisez les discriminations
qui sont subies par les personnes
assises et notamment par les femmes
racisées en suisse parce qu'évidemment à
chaque fois qu'on part de discrimination
les gens font comme si ça se passait aux
états unis bien qu'en france alors que
la réalité est tout autre
et c'est précisément pour cette raison
j'ai nommé ce podcast inconfortable le
but c'est de sortir un maximum de gens
de leur zone de confort pour aborder des
thématiques hautement inconfortable pour
remettre en question notre système
parce que oui ça avant tout une question
de système les discriminations ça se
résume pas à des agressions
interpersonnelles entre deux personnes
ou deux individus dans la rue ça va bien
au delà de ça aujourd'hui on parle d'
oppression systémique parce qu'on
constate qu'elle se retrouve dans toutes
les couches de notre société et à tous
les niveaux
d'ailleurs une étude de l'université de
neuchâtel montrent que les personnes
suisses issus de la migration qui porte
un prénom à consonance étrangère ont en
moyenne 30% de chances en moins d'être
invité à un entretien d'embauché et
c'est la même histoire pour trouver un
logement et qu'est ce que ça montre ça
montre que les fondements même de notre
société se base sur le capitalisme le
racisme l'hétérosexisme et bien d'autres
formes d'oppression qui se nourrissent
les unes les autres pour former notre
système un système qui excluent mme
méthodiquement les identités qui sortent
de la norme pour favoriser celles qui
intègrent la norme
et à partir de ce moment là on comprend
que le pendant de la discrimination
c'est forcément le privilège
et c'est pour ça que je vous invite
aujourd'hui à
déconstruire individuellement les
différentes composantes de vos identités
pour remettre en question vos privilèges
pour qu'on puisse ensemble lutter
collectivement contre les oppressions
systémique
et j'espère sincèrement que mes
réflexions pour inspirer les vôtres pour
qu'un jour ultime ans on puisse changer
les choses même juste un peu
et si aujourd'hui mon discours
parvient à mettre de la lumière dans vos
réflexions comme sur notre système c'est
qu'au fond ma mère n'aurait pas pu mieux
choisir mon prénom
[Applaudissements]
oh oh oh